with a nice giri after a draw against
sergei coriaci and Anish tell us the
finer points of this game well I played
through the black pieces and I think
Sergei was a bit surprised in the
opening because usually when you play
with the white pieces you put more
pressure than what he did today and I
think he was surprised before it's not
his bad move and I think expected that I
would play Drago's and applied for the
last few games in that position and I
played for the Queens gambit and cons
gambit is a very solid opening and it
seems he didn't have any big ideas for
today and okay if you are not prepared
in such an opening it's a big chance to
gamble and the way it ended all right
well now that you had such an easy draw
we're gonna put you to work
yes so let's say if you know mine I take
a walk around the horn and your
assessments of these positions now first
of all this game with the Comanche and
Wesley so just to show a moment that
occurred in the game the move rupee six
was played by an opponent ehe wit noted
this on the air that queen e6 does not
quite work after d7 this check and now
the move kingi to even loses the coin g5
check and the queen gets back to the d8
square and that's that so it's kind of
funny that here there's no way to get
out of this position on each yeah I know
it's a perpetual I mean it's a little
bit of a cheap trap that Wesley as I
said although by the way you know even
here like it's really a long one problem
here it's a long perpetual is cringy
taurog did to quench six can be and then
couldn't you wanna fruity one could you
v d8 yeah yeah amazing variation but
yeah again you get away with this kind
of fun yeah but basically Luke e6
doesn't change the nature is just a
tempting right to blunder but if you
don't go under it's not really changing
anything and he didn't bloody waking up
to rock f6 and you pointed out to me
that you see a way to make progress ooh
yeah well as I told you that first of
all there is obviously way to make
progress but most more important is that
you know you don't always have to think
about how you win but you should think
about first of all how your opponent can
draw and all your pawns cannot draw here
because there's no perpetual he cannot
push the Queen side pawns cannot do
anything and then if somebody cannot do
anything that's a good indicator that
you might be
to something and like yeah like we we
looked a bit with you here that white
first of all it's probably good to push
the pawn to h5 you know it's always good
to create some mating motives you know
with the Queen ones diagonal and the
rook on the back rank and then at the
right moment you'd mention another line
though that here this is a bit of a trap
I can seven yeah he didn't white wants
to go c4 at some point trading points
with BC because it before in c5 we
connected most and after be sequencing
for this extra pawn on this wing here
becomes irrelevant because both a points
are stopped by the beep on so it's a
good trade for white but what's
important is that the B sequence afford
there is no route 66 and yeah what's
right and that's why after a move like H
for black isn't some sort of at subsonic
because if you move the rook to a fade
there's gonna be c4 and if you placed in
h7 is going to be c4 as well because now
if takes takes you cannot take when you
see because in d3 and I already was okay
once you trade the see pawns you just
have a clean extra d6 pawn I mean it's
really far and I don't think although
you know obviously in practical game
that I chance to Knoblauch at some point
might do something desperate like Queen
h3 and hope for some perpetual but it
doesn't look like a perpetual just yet
and knowing in Nepal I think he'll bring
this one home
alright that would be a big result on
the event because one Magnus Carlsen we
know would win would have a big lead if
it was he so lost this one though again
between magnets there's a huge clock
disparity but what do you think about
the chances for Magnuson disk I thought
it was to be honest when I left playing
how I thought it was bigger for him
because I saw the contours of rook f6 in
this in this type of positions and
somehow it reminded me of some alpha 0
games were black queen is shadow of
somewhere on h8 and the rookies on f6
but here Levin found the brilliant
regroup with Queen f8 which I saw still
but I was looking the game very briefly
and I didn't realize that there is rook
c8 cuz I thought okay if he moved the
King and put the rock h6 Bishop d7
actually I will do the job but rook c8
is very strong now if we have seven you
get some endgame and otherwise black has
created some kind of counter play yeah
and I mean whatever kind of endgame is
good news for black because I thought he
sort of just busted but I was a little
bit of a little bit of an optical
illusion I mean just let's say if what
does get an extra temple like us if you
make some dumb move here and I do get
that I mean you just toast but yeah quit
if a threat on screen a three check and
takes rook c8 left defense very very
well so far
and the move just update the game after
work she did well
Queen to d3o he has to go back to just
seven yeah actually it looks really bad
for black still I mean I didn't see
Queen d3 to be honest and now I mean you
were actually stuck to the back to alpha
0 scenario I guess the only only trick
for black is that after a four King g8
h5 you have h6 I guess only move because
if you get h6 like when I said then we
are really down material 0 was down a
couple of pawns but then h6 is brilliant
yeah you you break this thing open and
once the Queen does enter the the game
you know with the Queen
the whites open King is gonna be
relevant I mean just with the rook and
the bishop you cannot do anything here
to the King but once the Queen joins in
there is some sort of an counter-attack
so I mean the biggest challenge for
LaVon is to overcome the temptation to
resign here I think I think once your
comes temptation he will make winter 7
you making Jade he will see h6 but I
think the temptation is very big to just
just yeah get sick and just know we
don't want to see any of that happen all
right let's which to another game of
critical to ding Lorraine versus far
beyond the Quran I didn't mean having
lost to Magnus but still with an outside
chance what do you think about this
position yeah this was a this game was
completely beyond me I mean starting
with like I am I'm a very dumb player
you know I just know that you're
supposed to put the deep on push it push
the deep one forwards develop the bishop
and the night
you know I mean this move Queen a4 is
just completely beyond me I mean from
which kind of universe is that and then
after night a7 I think Fabi blundered
this move I think after Queen t7 she
want to do something I don't know
actually what if she thought it's a pin
or whatever but after Knight is seven I
mean clearly connect for was yeah I mean
I don't understand why don't you let's
say go G for here okay maybe the point
is that there is some d5 here yeah well
probably it's just brilliant I mean I
don't know it
she's probably he probably wants to
stops on g5 business that's why he is
doing the sophisticated stuff but I
thought actually black was doing really
well here I mean I don't imagine when
you have the pieces here on the on the
first rank you can play the Queen f4 and
I mean this looks a bit like my game and
gets Magnus and I know that okay you
cannot enter as well sign of quick
learner I know that you cannot do such
stuff I think the fabric did very well
to trade off this Bishop for the night
because once you trade initial even the
second one because once you get rid of
the Knights suddenly if you protect g4
pol you are kind of in business and I
actually thought he might already be
better because the bishops are kind of
dumb and okay black has to go d5 but
even then de D you'll not change
anything so black has to cannot open the
position for his Bishop so g6 Bishop is
kind of passive for now of course black
still has I mean some sort of trumps and
maybe he's even better but I think vibey
did very well to somehow from this
position limited blacks dynamic
potential by because nights at the most
dynamic pieces yet they're the ones
jumping I think once you get rid of the
Knights you kind of are more stable I
think the England probably probably
should have maybe he can move the knight
here I mean either one probably he
should try to collect 97 try to keep the
night so don't compare says Bishop III
back yeah yeah I don't know maybe I
maybe start with h5 here yeah this was
maybe a good moment I don't know I think
he should have played more off because
once the bishop yeah this position when
I saw it I thought it was written Brenda
not so clear so he got 94 at GG now the
question is if the a pawn is a strength
or a weakness I mean it's probably a
weakness because it's a passed pawn with
the rook behind but
there's nobody supporting it and it's
also a question if the h-file is going
to bring you many mates it's a bit of
the unusual place working to be hanging
out on HD yeah I see the computers are
just an interesting option of
sacrificing upon but of course it's a
very concrete I mean you want to sort of
if it doesn't work I mean the show goes
on f5 you really look stupid so he of
course wanted to protect the pawn and I
don't think he had another way because
Knight h2 is very said King h3 is kind
of cool
usually you leave such tasks to your no
small members of your army for phones or
horses or or elephants but yeah when
nobody is there to protect protect the
little soldier sometimes the King has to
get the job done this current position
on the board your feeling about it
turned out finally the a pond is
probably a weakness I guess after rugby
6 you're almost losing it doc Quincy
four is there yeah I mean I think black
is doing like is doing well I guess the
you can pick up the a6 pawn but and okay
black why doesn't have any attack here
the bishop on g6 is not very active yet
but there's the idea of f6 Bishop f7
eventually I think black has blacks
better but fab is fighting and finally
is a good fighter if anything so alright
well let's go to one last game before we
let you go we see here shocked just took
a pawn on c5 and it could not be
captured 55 7 will just be a crushing
mating attack oh yeah also g5 looks very
cool I mean I don't know but just
I didn't calculate but I just was hoping
that d5 was but maybe after it D there
is no not initial maybe this is easier
yeah I think I know this variation
actually the thing about this variation
is that black wants to break with c5 but
whenever I tried that with the engine
it's always was a bad move because you
only open up the position further for
the bishops so I think it's extremely
hard to play for for black I think you
basically didn't get out of the opening
with a comfortable position and c5 I
guess is just a mistake now I mean yeah
you want to go c5 but because in this
structure you always want to go so far
you want to break
break you know the open the center but
here you only break open the you know
open the bishop you open the rock and I
think this pollution is very hard to
play over the board and you have to be
better prepared to play it just before
we go to the next game what's your
evaluation of mama D ROVs incredibly
precipitous decline from number two
player where he was 28 17 and now he's
27 50 and almost every single tournament
twice and he does badly yeah I mean I
had a very bad tournament in shamp here
and this one is also started the same
way but he had such tournaments like
every tournament at least I managed to
have some good events as well this year
but I mean I don't know I think it can
happen I think these tricks like you see
I mean with Magnus the opposite I think
and the shock he also had a streak I
think these streaks they are there for a
reason I think just as a very
psychological game and I think the it's
not accidental I mean if you are doing
well you have the confidence for example
yesterday when I played shock there were
so many decisions that you I could even
sense during the game that I mean for
example I don't know if you remember he
could have taken on a three leading to a
solid position but imagine okay he is
ambitious
Chakradhar he has this disastrous year
already and he will has to play some
slightly worse end game why would he do
that so he decides to play more
ambitiously
and then his son has to defend why would
he want to defend he decides to go on
Castle but by doing all that he doesn't
create any winning chances she just
gives me basically a point so I think
you start taking decisions which are you
start taking somehow the whole thing
into account like his if let's say he
would be twenty eight twenty he would
just play Bishop takes a three yesterday
and play solid and if you'd be in good
shape you'd probably manage to make a
draw and you know a point saved here
half point saved there already
everything is different I think it's
simply vital there are some points you
get out of the battery because the best
trick I mean right now I show here but
it could be anyone else I mean I recall
best tricks from any players there there
is no exception
muga knows he had a bigger slightly
bigger gap so when he has his bad streak
like he dropped from 782 from to eight
eight to eight thirty so it was not
possible but everybody's noticeable
people didn't know that yeah and it's
true because ice dominance often maybe
it was the time we were saying fab you
might surpass him now there's no such
time yeah let's say for Magnus is also a
little bit easier because people will
keep fearing him like even after he
drops 50 points but for sure he are
already people no longer fear him the
same way so well I just heard that
Wesley might be resigning soon and the
idea that you discuss after this
position didn't even desperate with this
move same for a nexus a take c5 and this
was like a disaster yeah but I mean what
he's did it makes sense because he saw
the support thing coming and with these
two a pawns against the b-pawn you're
just waiting for the execution so I
think he wants to create an outside past
phone with an i3 and hope that he can
combine the ideas of Queen h3 with a -
and somehow either Queen or generate a
perpetual but as we can see here with
the engine it just doesn't work so then
it looks stupid but the idea is
basically that here she would make two
moves in a rock finish three and a three
but yeah in that order you're not in
time because of g7 and in this order
probably I just pick up and probably I'm
just back like here you know you get
that extra temper with like basically
the whole business with before e3 was to
create that to get that extra tempo
because your queen is distracted but
then once I go back turns out that
finish 3 in itself is not yet perp I
think he thinks of rookie six and now
quit exit six that's important it's
actually not trivial you see so you have
to take because kh2 it was pleasant you
have to take care I also read before was
winning but actually this is clean
and now there is no professional devices
compared to the line we looked at before
with 23 it's only Q&A tool and then King
g3 so he did something desperate and
when you do something the desperate you
don't always calculate to the ante just
if no deeper side it doesn't work but
you hope that it will work and you just
okay a3 a2 pedestrian maybe job but no
very good insights actually I was going
to look at the Nakamura Sheila Graf game
but that certainly is not that critical
for us thank you so much for joining us
who sincerely appreciate it great
insights as usual and good luck in the
rest of your games thank you thank you
Rison thank you